what's up y'all everybody who is not out
there glad you're here at the all things
comedy Comedy Festival in Phoenix and my
name is Ian Edwards and this is the
soccer comic grant podcast and I put on
a Instagram that I'd be here this week
doing the podcast and that that one guy
that listens and watch a soccer in a
Phoenix I ask them to show up he's not
even here
that's how packed this joint is today
but it's funny I rode up here to the
comedy festival with my homie Dean I'm
going to introduce him to in a second
and I've known Dean for a long time like
three weeks and longer than that but
we've done a lot of traveling together
we done a lot of talking we ate a lot of
meals and I everything has come up in
all our conversations except the fact
that Dean used to play soccer I don't
know how I've done his podcast several
times we've done talk after shows before
shows never came up so luckily Dean used
to play soccer so I'm gonna investigate
his soccer past and pull him out the
soccer closet and see what he has to say
so right now we're in Phoenix just drove
in and we're at the all things comedy
pop-up store right is that what they
it's a pop-up store is that a thumbs-up
so I did that right and we have a
backdrop and the sponsors are
Bud Light so if you're like Bud Light
deal with that and another sponsor is
Tito's handmade vodka now handmade vodka
kind of throws me do you wash your hands
before you make the vodka is your nails
clean it's like I understand it's cool
to have [ __ ] handmade you know but maybe
not vodka that's all I'm saying yeah
gloves gloves made vodka
Tito's glove made vodka and city's
cityscape Phoenix was cityscape Phoenix
this this building alright so we're in
cityscape Phoenix and yeah let's just
have some fun talking to Dean about
soccer animal showing some clips
tell him Dean always tells me about a
lot of stuff so I'm gonna tell him about
some things
what up Dean thanks for thanks for being
here we are in the desert I always love
the this like we're doing the first all
things comedy festival right and and
then like five years from now when it's
huge we won't be invited you know one
person we took airline Greg up here yeah
smooth ride yeah I was I was rude as
[ __ ] I slept in tie away Greg you missed
this insane car fire oh no I didn't your
car was burned to the [ __ ] ground I
didn't miss it man I was sleeping on
purpose smooth [ __ ] engine cars for one
minute and goes to sleep you know why
cuz I stayed up all night yeah and we
were having a conversation I said I know
right Ian and Theresa I think I woke up
three times and joined the conversation
for a minute yet I'm just not to be rude
yeah after that I comfortably went back
to sleep you were faking like you were
awake no no I wasn't faking sleep is
real time dude I'd be sleeping right now
if we didn't have to do this right yeah
I know yeah I had to wake up to do this
[Laughter]
what's your name over there
ty Thanks and a man right here running
the boards Aaron see I'm not terrible
with Aaron Aaron
Nomi you've come to the studio in on
Melrose I'm on a show I'm on one of the
shows on the network yeah I'm gonna have
people at my actual show Erin and I go
way back we used to do the podcast there
and our rally studios yeah for like for
like a year straight I'm like I only
remember comics yeah and but I have to
see you like now now I have to see like
12 times yeah
to remember you yep yeah I remember one
time I did a show with some a comic and
then like two years later we're at I was
at the one-on-one eating with Jay Davis
and he goes yeah you know such okay good
to meet you guys
yeah we met before you opened for me
oh when was that like way I think it
last week or something I felt like it
digging us two years ago in Lancaster I
got two years ago I placed a place you
would want to forget dude I can't even
remember two months ago I got I got no
excuse not remembering artists that my
memory is completely [ __ ] like I gotta
try to remember him so that I can get a
ride back with him on Saturday morning
keep saying his name that's great from
Harley hey that's Greg Riley from El
Cajon Harley's monster I just slide my
sponsor in there slide this slide as
many things as you can in this thing
yeah so everybody knows that the topic
of my podcast is soccer and I usually
cover the Premiership and you know are
the things that are going on in soccer
but for real for real you didn't tell me
that you used to play soccer so when was
this
could you grew up in Yosemite yeah so
how do you play soccer on the rocks we
played soccer on Half Dome
yeah now once we moved then I was in -
where did you move - in the area and so
I was you know I played Little League
baseball right and then I played soccer
I didn't play football till high school
Oh
and I love soccer actually dude which
was amazing and our team was fire and
this was your junior high school team no
sorry I guess it's like fifth sixth
grade no fourth fifth sixth grade how
old we uh I don't know what age is that
like you know 10 11 12 9 10 11 but it
was the same guys each year and then we
would move up and he could grow together
yeah that's true girl we were good man
or and I remember you know like growing
up I'm 51 so here are your idols mm-hmm
you got Bruce Lee right exactly
yep you got Pele uh-huh those are your
idols well yeah because funny is like
like yeah like it's funny those are all
my idols and I grew up a completely
different place yeah then you got Evel
Knievel I did yeah yeah and then you
would have I had dr. J you know he was
like the first like super player to me
you know but Pele was really like
fascinating dude to me and you know
you're always trying to do the bicycle
kid oh yeah and it was amazing I was
watching some soccer recently for some
reason and they had like some highlights
on and so every American feels I was
watching soccer recently for some reason
it's never a reason for an American to
watch soccer yeah except the ones that
are really into this boy yeah but they
were showing guys doing the bicycle kick
still to this day and badass getting
that stuff in there yeah yeah but yeah I
played I think the bicycle kick is what
probably sold Pele and soccer to if not
the world but definitely Americans
that's like if you did in soccer back
then for an American if you want to sell
the sport you show Pele doing that move
and people like all right what's going
on over there
yeah because it's so air acrobatic it's
almost kungfu karate and basketball it's
a kung fu yeah
bicycle kick dunk into the back of the
net you know and then later on I was way
into Oasis and they were so into song
so then I kind of got into it again I
would weave in and out because they were
you know their their stage clothes were
kind of soccer they would have like you
know kind of like they wore adidas you
know like but not in a hip-hop way more
like real swim
adidas wetsuits and in that total like
you know European kind of soccer star
look that was kind of their look on
stage which was really unusual for rock
bands you know like what are these guys
winner in you know I think I think one
of them's a Man City fan big they put in
it what's his name
Noel Gallagher or Liam Gallagher and
that puts soccer and we do that and
these guys are soccer nuts and they
actually if you watch the documentary
they show them watching it a lot you
know let's see if we can find well
they're from Manchester yes there you
see the city or United I think a city
because I think I saw one of them at a
city game the other day and how long
yeah yeah pretty I mean these guys a
big-time soccer guys I think it's Cydia
if it was man you I would know but I
think a city yeah okay listen we don't
mind pauses in the podcast no yeah I
mean you know we did not mind putting
you guys to sleep there's a question
from I'll take that question for you
he's saying what's my my my thoughts on
America not making the World Cup I did
this on another podcast is I think it's
a blow to people like America needs
people to be aware of soccer right and
one thing that makes Americans who
normally wouldn't be aware of soccer is
the World Cup but the if they're in it
Manchester City via Manchester
Cydia if they're in it it'll be
televised more it's going to be
televised but people pay attention more
because they'll actually root for the
team like I don't watch women's sock on
a regular basis but when America is in
the Women's World Cup i watch that [ __ ]
and so do other people in the same thing
applies for American men's soccer so now
that they're not in it that you we might
we're gonna definitely lose the chance
to get more eyes on the sport and some
of those people might be kids who are
watching like like Dean be like hey let
me try that and go play at a young age
and you know no you don't know you you
might miss a bunch of kids who could it
could have been great soccer players you
know what I mean just to get their
attention so it's a huge blow but to be
honest every major country has pretty
much missed the World Cup before England
has missed it
I think Holland just missed it Italy is
in danger of missing it right now
so it happens you know so it is there a
recipe for our I'll repeat your question
just so people can is there a recipe
this also is there a recipe to getting
better at soccer one thing I know for
sure is there are a lot of basketball
courts and I got this idea from a friend
there's a lot of basketball I think
trying to remember I don't want to take
I think it was Stuart but if it's not
Stuart Stuart Thompson's one of my guest
he's a comic but they're our basketball
courts available everywhere like we want
to go play basketball right now we just
run down the street there's a basketball
court they should be many soccer courts
available so that kids could be like
have that as an option and find out if
they have a gift and then go down that
road of that gift but you don't have a
choice then you don't do you just need
to know you have a choice and right now
soccer is not one of the American kids
choices well I was just reading
that they say that soccer in the next 20
years is probably going to be bigger
just as big as anywhere in the world
because of the the head traumas from
football right like all the parents now
are not pushing their kids into football
anymore
come on brain damage yes yeah so what
they and this is true you can look it up
I can't remember what it was in maybe
espn.com aware but they were saying that
they're gonna be pushing them towards
soccer which is gonna be way more soccer
players and then we're gonna have like
some you know great American players
which is interesting thing to read about
you know I mean I mean that'll help
right that'll help and uh but you also
you know why people want to play
football like American football because
people are trying to make a living yeah
this is a this is an ambition driven
society like I was in Australia and I
was trying to I was asking some
Australians like what's the difference
to them between Americans and
Australians because Australia is like
very Americanized you know and they said
that their parents tell them hey you
know try to make a living but don't
there's no need to be like super
aggressive about it to the pump the way
Americans are like don't take yourself
that serious you know you know them you
don't take yourself that serious have
some fun enjoy your life and in
Australia like if somebody's famous for
for like three years the country starts
making fun of them collectively right
and I get done with them because it's
just too much so so they're not driven
oh [ __ ]
so they're not I guess the point I was
making like we're financially driven so
a lot of people right move towards the
sports that have a ton of money
well they don't they don't understand
how to make become a soccer star so
they're like I understand how to be a
but you could NBA or well there's
there's still not tons of money in
soccer like that's I'm saying you never
hear about this unless it's a soccer
player from Europe who's at the end of
his career coming to here
to play yeah you know and get a big
check there's not a lot of Americans
making a ton of money like that Landon
Donovan made some money but he also
played in Europe and came back and so
did uh this guy he plays for Seattle I
forgot his name but he just Dempsey
yeah Dempsey and uh and and and what's
his name he used to play for Sunderland
he plays for the US men's team Jozy
Altidore right and and and and Tom
Bradley son came back from Roma I don't
know why he should have stayed but like
but there's but you have to get a
special circumstance that allows you to
make a ton of money I you know it's
funny because soccer is kind of weaved
in and out of my life all my life and I
never really thought about it but then I
remember when the Bay Area got the San
Jose Earthquakes team and that was what
doing a in the eighties yeah looked at
UPS actually San Jose Earthquakes and
they play an MLS team I guess so I can't
remember it was so long ago but I
remember I'd go see him play you know
this is when you were a kid yeah
like what you is that they're still
playing huh well is this so let me see
the history of the San Jose Earthquakes
on American Wikipedia right yeah let's
see what year they started because
there's only four look at that 288 see
that's so this is when they had the you
know the teens with the Kosmos and all
that yeah exactly
so you had the San Jose Earthquakes yeah
so I remember our coach would take us oh
you have to see the games you know and
and you get fired up you know like oh
yeah they're quake is that the Goonies
is that what their nickname was the good
[Laughter]
[ __ ] like that was destroy sock I wonder
if they're in the MLS now because
there's gonna be a cosmos soon like they
brought the cosmos back right for the
MLS yeah but I don't think they're there
in MLS you I don't follow MLS
you know [ __ ] mobile who has the time
right like this premium soccer being
played in Europe in the German league
the Spanish league English league yeah I
don't have time to like really monitor
the American League as much opposed I
grew up on those leagues so you know I
remember when I started comedy I was
doing comedy for a couple years and not
missing a day non-stop
you know 365 days just going going and
then one day I was talking to Burr and
he said he goes hey man that's great
that you're totally going at it but you
gotta take a night off
once in a while or a little mini
vacation a couple days because you don't
want to just be writing about what
you're just doing right now you need to
you need to do other things and engage
in other things and last weekend I went
to f1 with him you know formula racing
oh yeah and and he told me he does a lot
of things and that's how he can get more
material get more material like he went
spearfishing or whatever like in New
Orleans when he was doing a movie there
and and all that kind of stuff in and I
look at it now it's like yeah watch some
soccer you know what some soccer man
yeah and then maybe get some material
out of it you know and and all that and
I and I truly believe in that cuz after
he said that I went to a concert I took
a weekend off went to Santa Barbara and
I wrote all kinds of stuff like just
being out of but you're also higher
though so you get how about this would
be fun as all things comedy psychedelic
soccer games so we take a gram of
mushrooms and it's indoor however you
know it's indoor like how you make it
indoor indoor soccer place you know what
what do you mean at the end or do you
mean we've go play yeah
guys that normally don't play soccer
yeah on psychedelics feeling sorry yeah
I have no part of that I would love that
might be the safest guard he's a guy we
can get the ball to because we're
incapacitated guys that a bunch of guys
yeah
we've very a very limited amount of
skill could barely kick the ball let's
make it hot well that would be an
amazing league yeah like I'm not
televised League that would be great
right psychedelic soccer people watched
it like the Grateful Dead would be like
their jerseys would be tied on and it's
just like out there loaded on mushrooms
I think some sports on drugs is Wade I
did some weird sports growing up I did
well no I mean soccer is not weird man
what the [ __ ] Dean I mean you don't hear
a lot of people talking about it but I
also did a speed skate rollerskating oh
yeah yeah and then I played hockey
well speed skating is something my
people just do in the park right well I
would argue race Yeah right
oh oh yeah yeah me and my buddy we were
fast as hell we were the fastest oh yeah
we went to they like state championships
no for real and when we were three guys
you your buddy and another dude
competing well you do you know it's like
a marathon you know you sir yeah how far
is the race how long is the race oh one
of them is 15 minutes really long that's
kind of like a pace one and then they
got a sprint one there'd be like three
laps you know that kind of stuff it
wasn't a joint when you go up on a side
and pass people right straight sorry
no that's roller derby I love that they
did it with the bikes any other way but
I thought they did that but yeah well I
member we went to the state championship
and we were we were going in its novice
and our coach goes you guys are smoking
Moll we're going as expert and then you
can get sponsors and stuff oh we got
smoke I mean we drove all the way to LA
from the Bay Area I remember
I think was Laguna Beach though and we
got there and it was like straight up
one of those sports movies you watch
where the parents show up with their
kids and motorhomes and they got like
three sets of skates and they're all
rich people massage in their bodies and
get em ready and we're ready and we got
smoked I mean but because there are
older kids in there like experts they've
been playing it oh my god we got it was
a long 10 hour ride home oh my mom was
so mad because you know we would have
came home with trophies but he had to
move us to expert did you quit after
that no but I I saw we started getting
into hockey and I was away in you know
hockey is like to me hockey and soccer
kind of similar yeah yeah yeah and I
kind of played the same position you
know
so when you so you said you was playing
he was like 10 years old he's on the
team yep and what was your position I
played right wing right wing yeah and
our team was called the Rovers the role
and this was and this was your junior
high school team while this was a club
team no it's like elementary school I
think it's called P P al week or
something pal pallie or whatever it's
public I don't know it's a what's that
kids it's it's like a popular name it's
like you put like is like a pump one
it's like it's just like Pop Warner but
what yeah that's it yeah that was my OC
y OC Csonka yep and it's like something
Youth Soccer League or whatever and I
was in that for like 4th 5th and 6th
grade oh cool all right
hey I think the other one the last one
over there yeah but we were we were
great there's the patch right there oh
that's the parents right there we were
great look headquarters California
been around since 1964 and you know we'd
play every Saturday and we'd practice I
remember on Mondays and Thursdays and I
just loved so that's the thing like
that's you practice Mondays and Thursday
Saturday why are you laughing we didn't
practice in practice every day exactly
so that's it that's the problem with
practice smoke speed skate these kids
they they're you're at that age they got
contracts with the club there in the
uses they they go to school after soccer
club they do two days and whatever when
I played football I became everyday the
field goal kicker smoked the field goals
dude I could kick the [ __ ] out of a
field goal I used to love that dude feel
golden yeah kicking yeah I think about I
think about the ball is so hard shaped
yeah I think I'd [ __ ] that up what
position did you play defense na
midfield Oh midfield yeah like right
midfield - yeah yeah so yeah and then I
use a pattern my game kind of like
Beckham as far as passing and like
Steven Gerrard like as far as like cuz
Stevens Rob would like the end to end
yeah but he was also he was one of those
midfielders who not only was a good
tackler but he's also a good passer
there's midfielders that are just great
at tackling and they'll get the ball and
then just pass it back to the other team
yeah and but there's there's the ones
that can like Gerard look like England
had a set of midfielders one time like
skulls Lampard Gerard and
[Music]
there's some other names but just guys I
could tackle pass and also score like
from long range
yeah so they were like complete
midfielders and now we don't even have
that like we got into we're in the World
Cup but we qualified with like the guys
we have now are not even no way at that
level and when we had those guys we
still didn't win the World Cup
yeah that's how talk to work okay yeah
yeah you know it's funny I remember
about most about soccer was it I it was
in the 70s and this is how much life has
changed
I remember it was straight up like Bad
News Bears we kind of have like the mr.
Buttermaker coach he would drink some
beers and stuff yeah but he had an
actual dune buggy those votes wagons
made into a dune buggy [ __ ] no street
cliche atole no seatbelts or anything
and he would drive like four or five six
kids in this thing and we like hanging
out the back of it on the freeway and
like and then after the game he would
take us always to get ice creams like
ice cream sundaes no matter what I
believe more kids didn't play soccer
what more could you want now how do you
how do you not kids want to jump in a
dune buggy yeah right out the back in
the Sun almost died play a game and get
some goddamn ice cream and sometimes we
play like in the pouring rain that was
right yeah yeah I used to love playing
for mud oh my sock is amazing that is
the best yeah Montauk is amazing Pig
soccer yeah is dope in England it's
raining constantly like during the game
like when you watching a premiership on
TV you like the way TV screens are not
right now you can be watching the game
for like half an hour 45 minutes and
then just notice that it's been pouring
like when they put an isolated shot on
that crowd right and you know wait a
minute it's been and it's just and they
wet the pitch all the time even before
the games to keep the grass slick yeah
people slide and stuff yeah it started
I know just it's I think it speeds up
the game right I think I make it faster
I love doing it Rain Man and you know
and I remember had Puma cleats yeah
Pumas Pumas was my cleat man for soccer
it was just the game and then we would
take a sharpie and our uniforms were
blue and we would blue the stripe on the
Puma ultimate uniform yeah remember yeah
I still do I still do I and Icicle to
the Pumas doors but they're all shut
down I'll go this Thanksgiving to the
Puma outlet the one in Camarillo right
when they have the midnight sale oh yeah
poor ones for life yeah growing up who
must were here doing him a Clyde yeah
was no joke that she was a soccer game
big time man big time yeah I had the
Puma cleats and I actually it was so
funny to think about the shorts that we
wore I liked it everybody was this is
saying shorts the basketball players
used to wear the pom-pom shorts those
are the me to shorts yeah yeah I think
he was asking for it in those shorts I
had a trophy for a while like we want we
won or do you win one year we we won the
city championship Oh get the partner
yeah yeah I mean one year we were
smoking really good did you score a lot
I scored a lot yeah I would score like I
could score like once a game get out of
here yeah did you did they ask you to
cross the ball in or you just came in
from the wing and tried to score I could
roll it down and you know I was into it
I was pretty good for a while and then
it's for you know once I got the seventh
grade I stopped playing because they
didn't have really soccer in school in
high school that's another thing a lot
of high schools probably don't have
soccer right I played soccer my high
school and it was a shitty team and it
wasn't shitty it was shitty because the
kids hadn't been playing it every day
all their life right so some of them and
some of them was South American and that
was fine but our coach thought he didn't
care he was really the baseball coach
making some extra money yeah on the side
coaching the soccer team so like on a
far as Fitness we didn't work a lot on
that and that plays a lot you know like
you know you're already not that skilled
and you going up a teams that against
teams that are just they just run
circles around you yeah you know Fitness
is huge so we didn't work on that you
know we did some drills we just didn't
do much and then you know every our
school was a big sports school like we
had a good football team and we had a
good well decent football team but we
had a really good track team so nobody
in the school unless you're on a soccer
team you didn't know the soccer team
existed in the school yeah
so which was good because when we got
our ass beat and they made the
announcements in the amount of how they
did in your high school but they would
make the announcements in the morning
yeah about how each team did and they
talked about the soccer team and nobody
would even hear that part which was
great because we we get our ass whooped
oh man
they had some weird sports in my school
they had bad meeting that was a sport
yeah like they played out in the
backyard with my brothers and sister
would go play people and then that
finding gas in a car a bunch of kids
badminton and then volleyball they had a
big volleyball that I get yeah I love
playing volleyball I love watching yeah
that [ __ ] is good like two men bought
volleyball mm-hmm that's great man
just like I'm like Beach yeah it's so
hard
there's no reason for me to watch me
or women's I'll even watch it during the
Olympics to the full on the the indoor
volleyball is excited yeah yeah like any
like yeah female water ball bearing all
the way yes beats man's spine will hand
down huh this is coming in spike in I
don't care what them dudes are doing no
interest whatsoever so that means I'm
gonna come back to you Dean but that
remember are in the beginning of the
podcast I said that one guy that pays
attention to soccer I'm Phoenix please
show up I think he did he's wearing a
man you is that a man you sure you you
look like it's um bro yeah I like how
you did a gangster like Phoenix ready
life you gotta act tough when you play
soccer around here they'll jump you from
other sports will jump you so what so
what League is that bring a medic come
alright some questions yeah see what
happens you show up to a podcast yeah
this guy could stab us it could do
anything we don't know sit right here
sit in the middle so Dean can grab one
arm and I can grab one on in case some
[ __ ] goes down and you throwing up gang
signs home so what's up man what's your
name what a victor talk to the podcast
here and I here for the soccer how did
you how did you know about the soccer
because I know about podcast I'm here to
represent and for the weekend thank you
so what do you live though I
just right here oh I mean you're him for
a week and you live here no but I'm here
for every show that you're gonna go to
that's actually that's a good one well
maybe tomorrow with Bert I have to take
off my shirt Burke tomorrow yeah
tomorrow no shirt here's my phoenix
rising so what is the phoenix rising
rising is here there one below there one
division below the MLS right the whole
point is we're trying to get to the MLS
you know Diplo yeah Diplo Pete Wentz
their investors so the whole point is to
get to MLS what do they need to do to
get to the MLS cuz they honestly we have
fans we have everything right now we
have a video player over here in
Scottsdale on the 101 and the - OH -
yeah it just sounds funny we sit on the
101 no that's what it is when you have a
stadium how many people as a whole I
think 7,000 the people who do you guys
know about the golf tournament so
everybody we don't know anything from LA
so we have a golf tournament
you know the waste management open they
do that big old 16th hole where
everybody goes in parties those people
made the phoenix rising thing and like -
in two months so the whole thing is
we're trying to get everything going and
so who have a bunch of other
professionals on your team or semi-pros
or just like mailmen you know yeah you
know Bravo
oh they play on the team who's in your
league is the Kosmos in your league oh
no no that's that's gonna be the MLS but
in the cosmos we were they were in there
but
okay they're trying to get like but
they're definitely go but they were
smooth Park Rangers we're all kind of
like the two teams like we're kind of
like to be low whatever but I say we're
trying to get to MLS what do we need
money or what
I think it's fans really fans obviously
it's money this is so but we have we
have drug bah did your job ah from from
this year he came this year he's a
investor player play for an MLS before
no MLS he played for Chelsea no no no
but didn't he play for an MLS team
before he came down guys he came
straight here you sure obviously he
played for Chelsea and then he came
straight to here Phoenix Rising and then
home our Bravo he played for Chivas
right from wala Hara he played for
Mexico we have on Shaun wright-phillips
I love showing right for this well he
plays for Montreal Impact first that's
an MLS team okay you're not gonna jump
this man I know you love phoenix rising
but you're not gonna jump straight from
Chelsea to let me see Phoenix rise
there's a step or two before he's an
investor Shaun wright-phillips yeah I
love Shaun wright-phillips you used to
play for Man City no I'm not a man City
fan but at that guy and he played for
Chelsea - I know you're not a man see ya
you pay for Chelsea - yes sir yeah but
uh we have China people here we're
trying to get it going into soccer it's
a soccer how do you go to games around
definitely season tickets it's for the
how much the season tickets for the
phoenix rising it was $10 what's to see
where's the season from - it was from
now until probably you know what I might
drive out one day - again LA Galaxy ugly
galaxy - yeah I mean I've been in galaxy
games galaxy - so we would play thanks
rising mm-hmm so they also your is a
galaxy LA galaxy - is it your league -
exactly oh okay what's the team that
plays where the Chargers play the
Chargers that's a galaxy but it's not
the do the charges play in StubHub I'm
not sure it's in the league it or is
there's a new la team in the league I'm
sorry on my mos how many leagues are
there in there's a league in each
country okay so the main league is that
one with all of Europe no there's a
league in each country so England has
the league is called the Premier League
the French have a league main league is
called league one but there's other
leagues
what's the week done everybody watch
that so Bobby Lee watches the
Premiership because he's asked if mr.
arsenal yeah there's mr. Arceneaux
bottle
yeah Kimberly but then they have a
Champions League uh-huh and the
Champions League is a competition where
like I told you in Europe there's a
league in each in each country yeah and
they all play each other to tuck the top
four teams from top four or three teams
from each country plays in a competition
oh that's the exact thing we want to see
is Barcelona vs PSG because PSG right so
we want to see Neymar verse let me tell
you so let me tell you this thing so so
in England well not anything in Europe
they have this thing called is a fair
play well not that it's about a like
financial fear play my bad finance
correct so a financial fear plays like
so you don't you want teams teams some
teams are going bankrupt just trying to
buy the best players right it's
unsustainable you know right so some
teams like because and fans want teams
to spend money to get the good players
so that their team can win but not
everybody can win and sometimes you buy
it spend a lot of money in the players
just don't work out for whatever reason
so they got financial fair play and you
have to sell as much as you buy right
right it's like a salary cap like a
salary cap but the cool thing is in
there is that they're all made by the by
the fans in Europe they're not it's not
a ship team if somebody's not like [ __ ]
like real much
like the fans choose what they want
there's like shareholders but I was just
gonna tell him how I'm a mutt Neymar got
to PSG yeah so Neymar played for
Barcelona Barcelona gave him a bar
applause of 226 million
yes he has a bio close like if you want
to have another team wants to buy this
guy yeah they have to 226 million pounds
or euros the guy gets a good money other
team the team gets the money oh wow
so then if a team is gonna buy him they
have to also sell that much or it has do
they have to have it in the team has to
have made a certain amount of money in
their budget from selling or just from
winning or sales or whatever to be like
and and you can only use a portion of
that budget to say like oh we're gonna
gonna buy this player because that means
it's bad business yeah so then so PSG is
owned by the Emirates it's all oil is it
goddamn country of oil yeah so what they
did to go around the buy our course is
the Emirates gave Neymar 226 million
pounds euros dollars whatever it is Wow
to say hey you're gonna be our
spokesperson for the Emirates and buys
himself out of his Barcelona clause Wow
and then PSG said hey you're free today
now the guy that used to play with Messi
and Suarez one of the most potent
attacks in the business is on this other
potent team in the French league so at
some some point they'll hopefully meet
no he goes on throughout the whole year
but the final
more two more groups to be next year but
I think he just had a birthday really
like doing a commentary or anything no I
think he's an ambassador man ambassador
for Argentina Argentina he's 77 years
old so he's from he's from Brazil so it
wouldn't be for Argentina but he's just
an ambassador have you attained attained
a certain level of soccer success yeah
you always make money
oh yeah just do appearances Ronald Ian
just goes places it just makes a lot of
money well I mean he was soccer for like
20 years no one ever said another guy's
name Oh Pelly yeah yeah in America
America yeah yeah yeah that's crazy
I heard of Maradona no no I never heard
of Maradona now he's probably some
people say he's the best that's what I
was thinking of you think about me not
to me Pelley's got three World Cups yeah
Wow and Maradona has one he almost had
two but then he got caught
doping oh oh you did caught people
riding back anything and he shouldn't
even have the one yeah you shouldn't
have the one because because he was
playing England I think it was a
semi-final or a quarterfinal in the
World Cup and he scored two amazing
goals one of those goals was a handball
and the ref didn't see it took them past
England they won 2-1 yeah yeah do they
got instant back then but they do now
though they do have the sight you know
and Champions League they have the side
judges where the goal because of that
because of back then yeah the refs are
right there so you have to know I know I
know they have champions
like the goal line yes son and then you
seen that I got a be paying attention
that yes I think they do and do you play
soccer
no I don't I love soccer never play no
no I play like I said I'm just I'm born
and raised in Arizona so I'm just your
parents are uh no from here okay you're
pairing all your parents Mexican yes yes
and you born and raised no it's funny so
let me ask others though what slap what
Glock is that that's the Phoenix flag
every excuse me we don't see there's
like a lot in a California so this not
even a soccer question you ever accent
right yeah you do you think so yeah I
would believe so I think that the main
thing that I was no no I feel that it's
like a Chicano accent exactly no that's
a pretty where did you develop the
Chicano accent in your home because like
a lot of a lot of Mexican people or
friends that I have have your accent but
they grew up in like like in my same
world so he's just funny like every but
I guess black people kind of have an
accent and a slang yeah this is your
[Music]
like I said I'm Chicano right so I
understand what you're saying like if
you talk to me in Spanish like listen
but I won't talk to you back in Spanish
from here in Chicano or Mexican if you
could say but no definitely not that's
cool
so you got any any other coaches any
question you want to ask me before you
know Dean I told you I had like one
listener in Arizona keep talking about
in was like dude you gotta get out of
bed this is gonna be rockin what up
Brett you do it you're good
are you doing something after this yeah
Brent's doing his part let's go get that
food all right
I don't know how much time do we have to
do air is this it oh we did it now all
right
did we 20 more minutes
I said nine yeah we started at 8:40
South we saw it for 7:45 and what time
is it now 8:45 so I think that might be
I want to drag it out yeah that felt
organically good that felt that was yeah
this is like after this I could come up
with some [ __ ] yeah but hey there's free
food somewhere so why blow that so again
I just want to Champion League what
about it
so who do I got who would at who do I
think about Champions League you know
what my team is man you I don't think
they're gonna win the Champions League
right
so I just want to see certain matchups
and so the teams that could win it
Bayern rial barsa PSG who
Boresha Russia Dortmund nah no I don't
think so
I think they I think they gave something
sold somebody right
they sold is it Dembele yeah so I don't
believe in teams that sell like their
best players yeah so Paul sick poles ik
is good but you know they need more I
just the team's I mentioned they're just
more loaded so so that's what I think
about that but like so I want to see
I'll just watch the Champions leagues
gonna be enjoyable and I'm gonna root
for Manuel they got knocked out and then
I can just relax and really enjoy the
rest of the tournament so who you got
who's your team oh yeah all right all
right no I respect that yeah I do I want
that too because that was a great that
was a great uh so he Sedin his a crazy
thing about I need a and bringing this
up because he'd mentioned the the crazy
thing about like Neymar leaving barsa
and going to PSG so there's there's a
group stage
there's a group stage in Champions
League I mean what's the other stage
then a knockout the group of 16 knockout
so you have to go to somebody's home and
play them and they have to come to your
home and play them and then the
compilation of the best of the results
determines who moves on to the next
round
so PSG embosser were matched up together
last year and barsa went to PSG right
and PSG hammered them hammered them like
I can't remember the exact score it's
like say 5 1 or some [ __ ] yeah crazy
some people gonna correct me on these
crazy goals yeah so then you know PSG
has to go to bar sir but you're like
barse is not gonna beat them by that
amount you know so this is over
on that day barsa went crazy and somehow
they managed to score enough goals to
win the whole thing and compensate for
all the goals that they and Neymar was
the one that scored the winning Wow the
gold [ __ ] okay we're gonna buy this yeah
and then and then now no yeah it's just
a funny turn of event I wonder what the
most goals ever scored was most goals in
a soccer game ever yeah but it's
probably not not I mean like like a real
League you know I mean because it's
always like 2 1
you know 3 1 or what you know let me see
like what if there's ever like a 22 want
like something happened let me see the
current world record for international
this is hilarious I like to know this my
my swingers cafe partners right there
yeah
we stand out front and talk for hours I
know there was this match right this is
this is FIFA match yeah 2002 I just made
Brent Weinbach laugh hard that is Archie
Thompson scored 13 goals against America
Samoa
in Australia's 30 1-0 victory 31 0
during the 2002 FIFA World Cup
qualification it's a pretty much that's
yeah that's that's abuse
thanks for having me dude alright can i
end the podcast he's got a pistol eres
good guess though it's how this is how
hot this podcast is the guests only want
to stick around to the end of the
podcast so just just just just got to
get over the hills and now I'm done
before the hill bro
so yeah here alone just staring at the
walls and stuff and the cameras there's
more cameras than me and people paying
attention to this right now but thanks
all things comedy Bud Light Tito's
handmade vodka again I questioned a hand
maintenance of the vodka it's weird to
have handmade vodka wood carbon
instruments or carvings yes you know
maybe even sheets engine parts but vodka
is weird people over there you're
probably here for the podcast after this
they definitely weren't for this because
everyone you pay an attention but I
directly looked at them and said people
over there so thanks man coming through
thanks again Brett thanks for showing up
early for your podcast
thank God I see yeah yeah so you gives
you an idea how to handle this isolation
yeah my name is being Ian Edwards I'll
be back again this weekend with a with a
full podcast after the game just weekend
in the Premiership and one love
everybody take care yourself it's a fun
festival let's do this got shows this
weekend and good [ __ ] night
sounds foolish sounds forward but how's
the place sound this full house the
place this empty sound so full